F
YOUR SATURDAY LOOK OVER HERE
TONIGHT WE HAVE DAVID RUBIN AS
WELL AS TYRUS BEFORE HE TALKED
TO THEM LET'S START HERE.
HOW ABOUT SOME GOOD NEWS.
THE ERA OF THE WOKE OF POLITICS
IS COMING TO A CRASHING CLOSE TO
BEEN HEARING THE COLLAPSE FOR
WEEKS NOW IT'S HERE THINK ABOUT.
BACK AT THE HELM AT DISNEY HE
WAS TO STAY OUT OF THE CULTURE
WARS.
>> DO I LIKE THE COMPANY BE
EMBROILED IN CONTROVERSY
QUESTION WORK OF COURSE NOT IT
CAN BE INSTRUCTING YOU CAN HAVE
A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
COMPANY.
AND TO THE EXTENT I CAN WORK TO
QUIET THINGS DOWN I'M GOING TO
DO THAT.
BRIAN: EMBED LOOKS LIKE A MAJOR
WIND OR FLORIDA GOVERNOR
DESANTIS FOR MAY COULD PAY OFF
THE LINE.
AND THEN NETFLIX, STANDING UP TO
THE BACKLASH OF ADDITIONAL BELLS
CONTROVERSY OR SOME PEOPLE
THOUGHT CONTROVERSIAL, KEYWORD
COMEDY CEO REED HASTINGS
STICKING TO HIS WOKE EMPLOYEES.
SHE DIRECTS OUR BRAND IS TRYING
TO BE THE MOST EXCITING AND
ENTERTAINING COMPANY IN THE
WORLD.
CHAPELLE'S DEAD CENTER FOR
OSPREYS THE BEST OR ONE OF THE
BEST ON THAT SPECIAL WAS ONE OF
THE MOST ENTERTAINING SPECIALS
WE HAVE EVER HAD ME DO IT AGAIN
AND AGAIN FREQUENCY -BASED
CONTROLS IN PLACE TO QUIT IF YOU
DON'T LIKE IT.
ANOTHER LA NINA COLUMN FOR THE
WOKE HOLICK'S LISTEN.
>> I AM NOT BENDING TO ANYBODY'S
DEMANDS.
IN MY CANCELED OR NOT?
LOOKS ALRIGHT, NOT ONLY ARE WE
PAST AWOKE, IT'S EVEN KIND OF
MISLABELED THINK ABOUT IT.
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT CAME OUT
POSITIVE FOR THE COUNTRY FROM
THE RUNOFF GEORGIA ELECTION, JIM
PROVE JIM CROW 2.0 IS LAID BY
THE PRESIDENT WAS FALSE WHEN IT
COMES ELECTION REFORM.
MEMBER THE OUTRAGE FROM MOST ON
THE LEFT?
>> TONIGHT'S LEAD JIM CROW 2.0
PER CRACKS IT IS THE PERNICIOUS
THING, THIS MAKES JIM CROW LOOK
LIKE JIM EAGLE.
CRACKS ARE REMNANTS OF JIM CROW
RUSSIAN NAMESAKE REMNANTS, AND
ATTEMPTED REVIVAL AT JIM CROW.
>> JIM CROW KKK -LIKE CARCASS.
>> IS THAT NUTS OR WHAT?
THERE'S NOTHING RACIST ABOUT IT.
HE IS NOT JIM CROW 2.0 FOR THE
GEORGIA LEGISLATION SIGNED BY
THE REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR SEEMED
TO WORK IN EVERY WAY.
PEOPLE ARE NO ISSUES VOTED ON
THE GENERAL ELECTION BUT IN THE
RUNOFF WHEN A DEMOCRAT ONE, GO
FIGURE THERE SHOULD BE SOME
APOLOGIES.
SO LIKE COCA-COLA, MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL DELTA EVERYONE SHOULD
APOLOGIZE.
BUT THE REAL NAIL THE COFFIN
CAME LATE LAST WEEK WHEN SENATOR
TOM CUT DESTROYED KROGER CHAIR
AND CEO FOR THE COMPANY'S WOKE
POLICIES NOTING A LAWSUIT FILED
BY TWO FORMER EMPLOYEES IN
ARKANSAS WHO WERE FIRED AFTER
THEY REFUSED TO WEAR APRON
SUPPORTIVE OF THE LGBTQ+
COMMUNITY.
>> I CAUTIONED THEM FOR YEARS
AND THE CONSERVATIVES AND
CENTER-RIGHT VOTERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IF THEY DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST THEM IN THEIR COMPANY
THEY PROBABLY SHOULD NOT COME
AND ASK REPUBLICAN SENATORS
SECURING THE WATER FOR THEM WHEN
THEIR DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS WANT TO
REGULATE THEM OR BLOCK THEIR
MERGERS.
I WILL SAY THIS I'M SORRY IT'S
HAPPENING TO YOU, BEST OF LUCK.
>> SIX YOU REAP WHAT YOU SO WE
NO LONGER BE AFRAID TO TAKE A
STAND FOR THE HOG HARD BOP FIGHT
AGAINST THE WORKAHOLICS IS
PAYING OFF.
WE ARE SEEING THEIR FALL FROM
GRACE RIGHT BEFORE OUR EYES.
EVEN COMEDY IS ALLOWED TO BE
COMEDY AGAIN.
>> NOWADAYS YOU CAN'T SAY
NOTHING.
IF I SAY SOMETHING NOW ALL THE
SUDDEN I AM INSENSITIVE TO THE
LIONS AND FAMILIES.
ONCE HIS LIEN IN THE CLASS
BECAUSE RICKY THANKS HE'S A LION
GET IN THE CAGE GET THEM SOME
RAW MEET MY KIDS DON'T KNOW THE
ALPHAB